qui nous a
fait une proposition qui était
relativement intéressante pour nous pour
pouvoir intégrer une un centre
commercial donc c'était la notre
première implantation sur une zone comme
celle-là finalement insolite alors pour
un magasin de vêtements de seconde main
on est au sein d'une galerie commerciale
et en plus vous êtes situés entre des
enseignes de prêt-à-porter
en effet
[Musique]
il y avait une vraie volonté de
s'implanter dans ce genre de lieu là
vous le dites une implantation dans un
une galerie commerciale et puis ça
évolue aussi avec le temps c'est que il
y a quelques années on s'est installé
plutôt en centre-ville aujourd'hui
via les politiques de responsabilité
sociétale et environnementale les
bailleurs ont tendance à aussi venir
nous chercher pour qu'on offre une autre
offre à leurs clients et donc ces
nouveaux pour nous c'est aussi nouveau
pour eux la seconde main se démocratise
et donc je pense que ça répond à une
offre assez globale et donc on répond
peut-être aussi à leurs clients qui sont
plus en recherche de ce type d'achat ce
qu'est le relais Val-de-Seine si vous
nous rejoignez dans cette émission et
que vous vous demandez justement ce que
c'est le relais Val-de-Seine son
président nous fait la présentation
c'est au micro de Mélanie poquet
[Musique]
on prend des gens qui avaient pas de
boulot pour une raison X ou Y on les
fait travailler dans notre entreprise on
les accompagne et à la sortie au bout
des deux ans ou avant on les a on leur a
permis de retrouver les codes de
fonctionnement d'une entreprise on les a
embrayés sur un parcours de formation
par exemple où on leur a trouvé un CDI
quelque part dans le dans la filière
dans laquelle ils avaient envie de
travailler
[Musique]
c'est juste un prétexte il y a un
gisement terrible en France qui est que
chaque Français nous jetons chacun
peut-être je jette moins aujourd'hui
parce que je donne au relais mais voilà
mais avant de connaître le relais les
vêtements étaient donnés ou jetés on en
jette en moyenne 10 kg par an et par
habitant en France des chaussures et des
vêtements donc on a décidé d'utiliser ce
gisement textile donc de collecter de
trier et de revendre pour permettre de
donner du travail aux gens en insertion
qui sont chez nous
[Musique]
il y a même un atelier qu'on vient de
créer qui s'appelle r où là on va
recaustomiser des choses donc là pour
les pour des jeunes ou moins jeunes qui
cherchent vraiment des vêtements qui
n'existent pas parce qu'on en aura créé
5 donc voilà donc on va essayer de
du plus jeune au moins jeunes de celui
qui a plus de revenus à celui qui a
moins de revenus vous allez trouver tout
ce que vous voulez dans la boutique
[Musique]
on disait il y a un objectif d'insertion
on va en parler dans un instant mais
dans le contexte actuel l'inflation
galopante le réchauffement climatique
aussi qui nous pousse peut-être adopter
d'autres moyens de consommation le fait
de se tourner vers des vêtements de
seconde main aujourd'hui ça fait de plus
en plus sens évidemment comme je le
disais il y a une attente sur différents
sujets sur une accessibilité avec le
prix puisque aujourd'hui quand vous
venez dans une boutique Le Relais vous
pouvez acheter 5 vêtements adultes pour
15 euros mixte homme femme et vous
pouvez acheter 5 vêtements enfants pour
10 euros donc vous avez une offre qui
est complètement accessible donc
effectivement
pour les personnes orientées petit prix
mais il y a aussi des personnes qui
veulent un achat engagé ou les deux et
qui s'orientent dans nos magasins ou
plus généralement dans la friperie
solidaire puisqu'on fait partie du
mouvement Emmaüs et je profite qu'on
soit plusieurs en plateaux est-ce que
vous les vêtements de seconde main ça
vous intéresse ce que vous avez déjà
acheté des vêtements de seconde main
j'ai déjà donné au relais à plusieurs
fois merci
mais justement comment arrive-t-il dans
la boutique ses vêtements quel est le
cheminement avant alors le cheminement
pour arriver à la boutique il faut déjà
effectivement comme Michael que des
personnes donnent dans les bornes donc
toutes les bords que vous pouvez voir
accessibles pour mettre ses vêtements
donc je les consignes dans un sac fermé
et des vêtements des chaussures du linge
de maison et de la maroquinerie on va
venir collecter ses vêtements toutes les
semaines ensuite on vient les trier sur
notre centre de tri à
Chanteloup-les-Vignes et ensuite selon
leurs qualités ils vont trouver un
débouché différent et donc la qualité la
plus belle est adressée dans nos 9
magasins en
Île-de-France
donc dans les boutiques du relais avec
une démarche d'insertion le relais Val
de scène travaille avec ces personnes
qui sont éloignées de l'emploi quatre
personnes dans la boutique à plaisir et
on va écouter tout de suite d'ailleurs
le témoignage de Mohamed qui est
responsable adjoint de cette boutique à
Plaisir écoutez un moment on covid a
commencé
pas moyen de trouver un emploi la seule
possibilité ça a été le relais
et voilà j'en suis content avant d'être
vendeur j'étais médiateur social de
proxor proximité 8 ans 8 ans de
médiation sociale
c'est une chance de leur donner voilà de
cette opportunité de rebondir peut-être
de se réinsérer de revenir dans une
démarche d'emploi alors c'est une chance
c'est eux qui pourront lire je dirais
c'est une opportunité d'être une
entreprise d'insertion et de pouvoir
proposer des emplois à des personnes qui
ont besoin d'un accompagnement avant un
retour à la vie
d'emploi plus classique et donc
l'accompagnement qu'on propose c'est
effectivement avoir un emploi et un
accompagnement qui est suivi par un
chargé d'insertion professionnelle pour
lever les freins à l'embauche donc soit
des freins sociaux notamment liés au
logement des freins de mobilité et puis
ensuite de découvrir son projet
professionnel c'est clair pour certains
et ça prend plus de temps pour d'autres
la Mohamed ah pardon la Mohamed c'est
une personne qui a eu un parcours
d'insertion qui s'est fortement engagé
dans la vente et qui s'est vu du coup
proposer un emploi pérennes chez nous de
responsable adjoint pour pouvoir ensuite
accueillir d'autres personnes en
parcours d'insertion et transmettre
c'est compétences et savoir-faire il y a
une réussite d'ailleurs une fois qu'on
passe par le relais Val de Seine pour
repartir justement vers l'emploi donc on
a comme on est une entreprise
d'insertion on a on est conventionné
avec la Direction du Travail donc on a
des objectifs à atteindre de minimum 70%
de ce qu'on appelle une sortie positive
donc ce sont des personnes qui vont
retrouver soit une formation qualifiante
soit un emploi à l'issue et donc on a
atteint nos objectifs sur 2022 et on
travaille encore à les faire progresser
pour l'année à venir sur place on
retrouve du textile dans cette boutique
il y en a pour tout le monde c'est
finalement comme dans une boutique
traditionnelle on va dire homme femme
enfant homme femme enfant de la
maroquinerie et puis une nouvelle offre
d'uby donc on avec des vêtements qui
auraient dû être recyclés qui étaient
trop abîmée on est en recréé une
nouvelle collection et donc ça c'est la
nouveauté de 2022 puisqu'on a créé 10
nouveaux emplois sur le dernier
trimestre 2022 et donc on a une offre
dans toutes nos boutiques d'offres
upside clé sur des collections
thématiques mensuelles et vous parliez
des tarifs alors j'ai lu chez nos
confrères du Parisien par exemple une
veste d'une très bonne marque italienne
était proposée par exemple à plaisir à
contre 800 euros dans le commerce au
prix neuf il y a différents types de
tarifs alors il y a différents types
donc effectivement là c'est
effectivement l'exemple un peu suprême
en fait c'est que les prix fixés sont en
théorie un quart du prix du neuf et
ensuite pour de les vêtements
plus basiques on va avoir comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure une offre
accessible en lot de 5 Pièces pour 15
euros sur les pièces adultes et vous
pouvez mixer femme et homme et pour les
pièces enfants du coup c'est 5 Pièces
pour 10 euros au-delà naissance jusqu'à
12 ans et donc pour prendre récolter ses
vêtements comme Michael l'appel à passer
au téléspectateurs c'est de donner ses
vêtements de les donner dans dans les
boîtes dont vous y référence c'est box
c'est ça donc de faire le tri sur ce
qu'on utilise pas parce qu'il y a
beaucoup ça de ce qu'on utilise pas et
donc de donner une chance à des
personnes en donnant ses vêtements c'est
en fait faire un geste pour créer de
l'emploi et donc effectivement on vous
incite à faire ce geste et premier bilan
depuis l'ouverture depuis octobre depuis
novembre est-ce que ça ça marche cette
boutique à plaisir alors c'est une
boutique effectivement qui est en
démarrage donc il doit trouver son son
rythme classique disons
et donc effectivement c'est une boutique
qui fonctionne bien qui a un flux et les
clients découvrent cette nouvelle offre
et c'est une nouvelle clientèle pour
nous donc on travaille à s'améliorer
toujours et quels sont les projets pour
2023 du coup alors les projets
on cherche à se développer à s'agrandir
et pour ça il nous faut davantage de
textile pour créer toujours davantage
d'emploi donc on sait que
chaque citoyen
achètent près de 10 kg par an et par
habitant et donc en jette ou en redonne
quasi autant et donc dans les Yvelines
on est au même en Île-de-France en
général on est à peine 3 kg par an et
par habitant donc en fait on peut encore
progresser dans le gestes de te trie
merci Emilie Morand d'être venu en
parler en plateau je rappelle que vous
êtes la directrice du relais Val de